- Good morning, Believe Nation.
Today's message is-
- Turn pain into greatness.
Over to you, Machine Gun Kelly.
(rooster crows)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- People used to take my
raps and crunch 'em up
and throw 'em on the ground.
I used to get made fun of all the time
'cause who believes that the guy sittin'
next to 'em in math
class is going to blow up
and become a superstar?
You don't believe that, right?
But you should have and it's a bummer.
'Cause, I don't know, man.
I mean take it and pain
is the best inspiration.
So if you're a creative out there
and you're getting bullied,
take it and make
something great out of it.
- So what do you think?
- I think that' a really
important message.
When I first started dancing,
I was told that I would be
a decent dancer, at best.
- At best?
- At best, at best.
I wasn't very good and
my feet are actually
not equipped to dance because
I have really flat feet
and I used to get a lot of pain in my feet
and it would always shake,
especially during performances.
I told myself that I'm
going to make myself strong.
So I did really, really
painful ballet exercises
and eventually I became stronger
and now I'm able to go
on stage and perform
and also change the physiology of my foot.
I wish I could show you
but I can't right now.
But I never had an arch
but I have an arch now.
- Wow.
- Yes and to most people
it's not a big deal
but to me is a huge
deal because I was told
I couldn't be a dancer because of my feet.
- Cool.
When I was at my agency, when
I first connected with them,
they told me that I wasn't
good enough to join the agency.
They liked my message but
I couldn't speak which hurt
because I'd already done
two years of public speaking
and I felt like I should
be a little better
than I can't speak.
Most of the people at their agency,
they said could speak but
they didn't have a message.
So they were willing to take a risk on me.
I worked really hard.
I wanted to take that pain, that rejection
and turn it into something amazing.
So I practice every single day,
working on my creation story.
Sometimes three times a day
making videos back and forth
and back and forth.
And I started getting better.
In a couple months I
became the best practiced
at the agency and people were saying
you should go look at what Evan's doing.
Not because I was great.
I had the least talent of anybody there.
I just worked hard.
I was making three videos a day
where most people were
having a hard time coming up
with one video a week, coming with excuses
that say I don't have time
to make one video a week.
More than that is just too much.
That's why I got better.
If you have a goal or
somebody's telling you
that you can't do it, it's just work.
Put in the work, get better at it.
Practice, practice, practice.
You can become a better speaker.
You can change the physiology of your foot
and become a great dancer.
Whatever your goal is you can chase it
if you put in the work.
The question of the day today is:
- What is the pain that you're struggling
with right now to overcome?
- I love it.
Leave it in the comments.
We'll join in the discussion.
Finally, want to give
a quick shout to Ron.
Ron, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book: Your One Word.
It really, really means a lot me
and I hope you're enjoying the reading.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
We believe in you.
We hope you continue
to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
and we'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another
- Shot of espresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
(keyboard typing)
- One does have to be
focused on the short term
and money coming in
when creating a company
because otherwise the company will die.
A lot of times people think creating
a company is going to be fun.
I would say it's really not that fun.
I mean there are periods of fun
and there are periods
where it's just awful.
Particularly, if you're a CEO of a company
you actually have a distillation
of all the worst problems in the company.
There's no point in spending your time
on things that are going right.
You're only spending your time on things
that are going wrong.
There are things that are going wrong
that other people can't take care of.
So you have the worst.
You have a filter for the
crappest problems in the company.
(laughs) The most pernicious
and painful problem.
I think you have to feel
quite compelled to do it
and have a fairly high pain threshold.
There's a friend of mine who says
starting a company is like staring
into the abyss and eating glass.
And there's some truth to that.
The staring into the abyss part is
that you're going to be constantly facing
the extermination of the company.
Because most start-ups fail.
It's like 90%.
It could be 99% of start-ups fail.
That's the staring into the abyss part.
You're constantly saying, okay,
if I don't get this right
the company will die
which can be quite stressful.
Then the eating glass
part is you've got to work
on the problems that the
company needs you to work on
and not the problems you want to work on.
So you end up working on problems
that you really wish
you weren't working on.
That's the eating glass part.
And that goes on for a long time.